[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اجمل النجوم الثريا واجمل ما بالكون القمر
واذا اجتمع الجمالين الجمال الكوني القمر
وجمال النجوم الثريا قال العرب القمر قارن
الثريا فالمقارنه معناها الاجتماع فاذا
وقعت ثريا بجانب القمر في اليوم السابع من
الشهر الهجري قال العامه
على بدايه ظهور الربيع فبعض الحلال شبعان
وبعض الحلال جوعان وفي قادم الايام ستنتهي
شده البرد واللي يبيعك بالرخص وقت الشده
بعوه ببلاش
واقترحا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واهم الاقترانات سته اثنين شتوي واثنين
الربيع واثنين صيفي الشتوي انتهى قران
عادي برد مبادي و جراند تاسع بارد ونحن
الان نعيش في اول الاقترانات الربيعيه
جراند سابع وجران خامس وهذا هو الزمان
وجربت اخوان الزمان فلم اجد صديقا جميلا
الغيبه في حال بعده وكم من صاحب عاشرته
فما دام لي يوما على حسني
عهده
[موسيقى]